whoa filming and filming Wow matrix um
so I am filming now a mail vlog and this
is behind the scenes of me filming this
mail vlog whoa and you probably like why
is she filming herself filming this and
you'll find out
are we watching prices wakes that was a
cliffhanger remember that game ah well
okay I need to stop I'm getting confused
on what I'm doing stop there but let me
shut my window really quickly stay right
there keep it babe do you do you knew Oh
privacy shut this because i'm a hermit
crab there we go and let me get okay i
have some mail that I've had for so long
that I need to open and I just I don't
know why I haven't done it have been a
an [ __ ] some would say um and I have
a little Jersey poof going on hey so you
know i'ma girl okay so um let's start
Ali Hancock's got a funny little name
there huh she drew a star of this yes
you do a star yo yo yo yo yo E I'm
drinking kombucha because I'm a little
bit hungover whoops whoops all the
website let's open whoa creative okay um
well we got so many things in here Oh a
painting you've been hey stupid hey you
stay like race day oh this is awesome
great job you painted that and it looks
beautiful hi grace I apologize in
advance for my messy handwriting oh
please it's beautiful I've been thinking
for days of what to send you along with
this letter I'm still not sure but I
will come up with something I just want
to tell you how your videos really gives
me a chance to smile yeah I love always
a lien talks thank you for this letter
is so sweet I feel like I just ate a pie
and I'm full of sugar right now and then
someone someone got a case of the haha's
and sent me this Victoria's Secret
catalog whoo the pushup
it gets their attention oh I get it
because of the exercise boobs boobs
butts boobs butts butts boobs butts and
boobs and boobs and butt surprises but
oh and there's some tits and butts and
push those hips out ladies great reach
highly recommend some we're reading this
no it's fall now ok let's go forward
whoa what is this is a crazy low letter
long reach high school columbia maryland
what from a mall oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh my gosh oh my oh what oh
are you asking me to order we're hoping
to raise much-needed funds through sales
of magazine subscriptions oh you want me
to order magazine from you maybe but I
move so much in New York all the times
that I'm pretend pretentious I am
nervous about ordering things because I
will have to do all that work to get the
address change and this is an excuse
because I really don't want to look at
Exeter but this is I hope that you're
selling them I'll think on it I'll think
on it thank you for thinking of me as
someone to give you money yeah um ok
next whoa be mingming songs dramatic
this is from Sarah Daniel huh she's got
two first names I've never met a girl
that has to first girl names crazy thank
you oh look at those flowers are so tall
like my legs grace Helbig more like
grace smell big you've been hazed go on
girl why did the blonde stare at the can
of frozen orange juice for two hours
because the cat's eye concentrate I know
that game ha I'm 14 years old I like
watching your videos sincerely Sarah
thank you Sarah this is really nice of
you I have to sneeze get a sneeze get
out of me thank you Sarah that was so
sweet David and Christina from lemon
grove california that sounds like a
place on
on the candyland game board what is it
what is it a tiny envelope with them hey
what's his face the rabbit Bugs Bunny I
was both money for halloween like three
years in a row so if i wasn't going to
grow up and be a funny person i don't i
would have been a probably serial killer
hi grace me and most of my family love
your videos who are the ones that don't
good inc that's really sweet thank you
working as we speak to get the rest of
them to love your videos too oh that's
so sweet thank you my nine year old
cousin loves you and insists on watching
your videos on the back he wrote you a
little note ah dailygrace you rock and
you are cool for making a video you have
been H word from david oh then it's so
sweet thank you guys this is wonderful
oh that's keeping pace is a bad word
it's not a bad word but if you don't
feel comfortable saying it that's okay i
support you nine year old child that
probably shouldn't watch my videos
because some of them are adult content
yay thank you for that letter that was
so sweet okay next we got Oh nor my
postcard Norway more like no way because
you suck no reason hey what can I house
is that this looks like three houses
that are but effing each other just
kidding that's there are nine Europe
that watch my videos hi grace so I
decided to write today's letter already
because oh this is from Zoe's oh it's by
gay thank you so II I was wondering
where you were girl and is this also
from no this is pelicans and penguins Oh
their rivals segregation look at that
segregation that's amazing hi grace it's
grace what this is a letter from Grace's
postcard smells I've never been to the
benissa islands Oh nor do I think
pelicans and penguins hang out they
don't look at that look at that crazy
house going to make a back of the bus
joke and then I realized that no don't
do that from gray steel or grace Ted
something like that awesome thank you
for this
car that is so sweet next miss didn't
miss Dennett why can I see Denise miss
Denise and Ventura whoo you fancy huh
let's see open letter aha I letter whoo
look at this you wrote it in pencil Oh
smeary dear grace Helbig more like
Grace's tell a big you suck you guys are
really nailing me today let me just tell
you but you so why you said because I've
treated you a lot and you can have never
been hazed I'm sorry not everyone can be
haste that's why it's interesting uh
anyway I'm buying a shirt yay you should
have run um when you want to send them
to me so I can sign and or write
horrible insulting witty things on them
um please don't do that because I
probably will forget to send it back to
you I am NOT responsible as much as I
try to be from Beth Kirwan and Alex
stretch aka my alter ego you crazy this
is so fun thank you for um PS my father
Patrick was a potato oh please tell me
you've seen my drunk kitchen on youtube
if not and this is oh so [ __ ] watch
it I have seen my drunk kitchen I don't
prove it apart but awesome thank you for
the letter so cool so cool oh and you
have your homework on the back precalc
homework number one did you do that did
you forget to do that that's cool I'm
glad that you use that paper for writing
me a letter instead of your homework yay
jennifer wright from harper woods
mission again people initially my old
letters you guys are just so much oh my
gosh there's cupcakes on this paper this
cupcakes on this paper I want to eat
them greetings Chrisman is jennifer and
I live in Detroit Michigan I've been to
Detroit for wedding and I did not get
shot so I considered it a great time I
wanted to write and let you know how
much I love your videos you're hilarious
also for
to my daily grace things are pretty bad
in troy but your videos always make me
laugh get out of there I don't know what
else to say uh I look forward to seeing
you in your next video Jennifer the glam
goddess for life Thank You Jennifer for
this look cupcakes cupcakes can't be all
bad if someone in Detroit sells paper
that looks like this thank you good luck
I hope that you don't get murdered or
crime against you get out of there
that's all i can say thank you for the
letter okay next is from deborah
salisbury my mom if you change your mind
I'm the first in line honey I'm still
free oh that's from that change by that
girl salsbury my mom used to make sales
dry sticks for dinner when we were
younger and I remember hey keep calm and
Hayes on this is awesome already this
rules whoa you put band-aids in here
these are the most clever unique
inappropriate item I can find a sin you
also are you sensing a pattern I really
their band aids with wood naked men on
them no no no look that band-aid has a
naked cowboy on it can you see that look
at that oh my god I have blisters on my
feet but I don't even want to put these
on I'm just wanna look at them oh I'm
not attracted to that man I don't know
it's probably good this is awesome Thank
You Deborah this is a great card I won't
read it it's got a lot in your hmmm your
hand and chip is awesome um okay next
move through we got some more to go this
one grace Helbig who it's from the Queen
from paw i'll be on something like that
whoa it's already been open oh my bad
the people at the post office just can't
help themselves ah hi grace I made this
car for your birthday so I hope it
reaches you around the right time sorry
for saying [ __ ] on the Front's
because I made a few days before you
officially retired the slogan if not cuz
I'm trying to hold on to the post hope
you like it oh my god
oh my God look at this card this is
awesome Wow oh no all those martinis are
falling over that's such a waste oh this
is so cool thank you so does it open oh
whoa happy birthday hope you have a
really fun day erase all the roofs and
all the houses eat some cake oh look at
all the things those are I own all those
things except for the draft I wish i'm
in that draft Wow made in England thank
you thank you thank you this is so cool
you guys are so creative okay this is
also from an anonymous person oh my god
and oh go okay give this get into me
well well we were a whoa whoa whoa whoa
Duggars my name is and am le I'm a 15
year old girl from Norway ah Norway has
weird names for the girls and I think
you're the funniest person in the world
i watch your videos every day before I
go to school you always make me laugh do
you remember when you posted this
picture on dailybooth i drew you and you
hate me huh yeah I didn't remember this
picture that's me that's me see oh it is
identical thank you thank you so much
mle maybe I'm saying it wrong Emily
probably Emily and you guys spell it
crazy and you put this like that looks
like it should be a tattoo on a Guido
that's awesome thank you so so much
that's so sweet of you okay next
connects get through these grace give it
whoa this is from Brandi toros from
mcallen texas everything is bigger in
Texas look at that whoa okay go don't
ruin what's inside and I'll ruin the
envelope grace oh that's me it's a tiny
envelope inside of a bigger envelope you
are Texan my god okay
I have I own about seven letter openers
now and guess what I'm not using them
I'm old school my name is brandy and I
have a lez be honest crush on you your
videos lover videos you complete me I
love your smile by eps I'm joining the
Navy and one and hope you pray and make
or say something about it in one of your
videos that would really make my day
brandy well brandy good luck joining the
Navy you roll it go sink all those
battleships next thank you for that
letter brandy that was really sweet
Italy oh it's from Joey haha first of
all working on my handwriting through
isn't it pretty so pretty I'm talk to my
friend Kevin right now and he absolutely
loves you hi Kevin I love you too Wow
Thank You Joey this is really little
girl okay what's next is Brittany
blankenheim from Oshkosh Wisconsin oh my
gosh oh my gosh gosh ha ha I swaraj kosh
b'gosh clothing whoa birds birds birds
birds birds grace you've been hazed k
bye love it love it I love it and I love
it That Bird speaks English Oh Wisconsin
you guys are awesome thank you for that
that was great okay now this is from oh
they put little guys look at those
little guys they put them there they
look great the colors look awesome who
is this from a visit from and why
wow really good thing what uh it's a
hair clip look you put it in your gonna
put it right bing I'm so beautiful thank
you who is this from now whoa what's up
[ __ ] hey grace I just want to let you
know that you're totally all so amazing
I really look up to you and I love your
videos hands down you're my favorite
youtuber best of luck in the rest of
your career from Karen 15 from England
and she drew this picture Karen this is
awesome thank you so much and thank you
for making me more beautiful hey
accessorize this is awesome thank you so
sweet so sweet we're getting to the
young guys urgent telegram oh no from
Columbus Ohio oh no Christopher Columbus
to me tonight whoa what is what oh my
gosh western union tension grace Helbig
millions are outraged by recent end of
[ __ ] breeding stop suggests reminding
viewers this is your damn channel as
name would submit stock loyal viewer as
long as Daily Grace never stops stop
best regard until further communication
stop what this is Christy with us a--
from what this is look at that thank you
for this i'm sorry that you are upset oh
this is funny 646 i am go to sleep are
you doing up so early oh my gosh sorry
what's a [ __ ] stop but if you love
something to let it go this is some
kiera king and winnipeg where's Bennett
egg I don't know a brain just
malfunctioned open letter you take this
letter up so good that i'm just going to
ruin it Oh yellow paper your old school
yeah whoa there six
grace along with this letter i'm sending
knew what i like to call a haze monster
what it really is is a bookmark that
slides onto the top corner of your page
to keep its place oh my gosh wow look at
it look at this little guy so you put it
on like this I'm assuming I'd it holds a
puck look can you believe it and it says
you've been haste on it that is so
awesome I am a current follow of yours
on tumblr when pigs fly with
kaleidoscopes tumblr com I hope you get
this all the way from Canada hope you
have a wonderful day kiera king Thank
You kiera king this is the most adorable
thing and makes me want to read so i can
use this so that's beneficial awesome
what's next we got this thing grad from
marissa marine Carneys Point New Jersey
where's carneys point oh there's a
bracelet Oh what's it say Air Force
Junior OTC and then it says here a box
okay and there's a minute give me this
leather what is it hello grace my name
is Marissa and I'm from South New Jersey
yeah me too I'm a senior this year and
hope to go to college after this year
hope my penmanship is readable the first
in the great city of souls are viewing
the Casey Anthony trial at that moment
you drew me and you've been my marvel
days better by making me laugh most
recently my first day of school suck but
I came home and watch your latest videos
and you definitely made my day better
well you deserve to have a good day so
I'm glad that worked Marissa in my air
force JROTC unit we sold hero bracelets
where the money was used to buy items
and airmen couldn't get when he or she
is stationed enjoy the bracelet grace
you're an inspiration Thank You Stella
so much Marissa this is wonderful I hope
that how soldiers are doing still there
still so that's a funfetti cake down
there yeah they love it down there
that's why I love it thank you for this
bracelet that's so awesome of you and I
hope that you have better days at school
it will have
it ok this is from I think this is the
last thing right last last last yes last
yeah this is the last one from Sean k
ken coran something like that from
Pierre South Dakota Pierre South Dakota
isn't that the capital I remember
learning nothing like why is some French
city the capital of South Dakota
education uh-oh what's in here what is
going on in here miss oh my goodness
what is this okay miss Talbot keep
rockin your videos I fear the day I may
have to start paying for them i'm still
working my way through your videos but
yet i have not seen a professional
wrestler gimmick i keep my fingers
crossed keep up the great work can't
wait until your regular for real and
aots Sean Thank You Sean AKA blow blow
blow FX BL 0 FX cool what is this when I
was in the Army I received a few
challenge coins although my experience
at the Army has left me quite tainted I
always thought the coins were cool thing
so I had a batch of my own made there
was only a hundred and sixty nine of
these minted maybe they'll be worth
something one day when I am undeniably
famous har har if the paint peels it's
because the coins have been through some
extremely extreme temperatures whoa whoa
coins look at this it's it's sat on them
well there is no tomorrow coin of God
2009 that's kind of sad rolling hard and
loving it Wow and you can meet things to
put the coins in where's our another
question no sir that's so cool thank you
for that Sean that is really cool I'm
like afraid to touch them these are you
made these how did you make these
everyone is so good at making things my
god okay I'm gonna go now but thank you
guys so so much for the letters and
trinkets and all of it is just 0